how's it going bros my name is Pierre on
the back welcome back to the main
welcome actually back to some more Ione
I bet you weren't expecting that or
maybe what I don't know I got the tip of
the writing South Park I'm sure you're
all familiar familiar with the show
apparently you'll get a different kind
of story a short story and I wanted to
see what it's all about so we actually
gonna try that soft barclays girl
okay I gotta miss Consuela's oh wow
they're actually stop by we had three
out of our room out of my house cache of
town the shadows monster life a
timeshare oh yeah I get to do that all
the voices it's a lot to play the other
on the inside it's just me or is it
calling here hey guys hey guys let's go
home ah his haircut is a lot different
from them it's gone guys
dad What's Wrong Takeshi you're such a
[ __ ] dude scared
skree gettig I am that what de frança
what happened dude
what oh my god oh my god they killed
Mika yeah bastard okay
Oh
sexy all right let's do the couch thing
come a brown come here brownish kid whoo
don't you better recognize [ __ ] oh wow
can you actually play them entire game
my elder don't smile for maybe I can
nah it's impossible it's impossible it
make no [ __ ]
ah poor Mika the bastard yeah me guys
guys
you killed Oh Kenny Kenny I don't know
why I lost something it's embarrassing
all right what happened
wait am I supposed to play the game
exactly the same with the play charnel
that [ __ ] it's impossible let's see yeah
holy [ __ ] the Play chart is there I
can't pick it up and I'm painting that
was Chang then what the [ __ ] died of a
key I could go here so maybe there's
something here happy I love to share
baby I can add a key all right good
enough
I share what's bugging anima staticky
let's just check all the rooms okay I
mean one guy ran over here right no I
find all the items
all right I bring this I know there's
like something in the toilet maybe no
not what do you want from me maybe that
was it I don't know me
got bottom oh wait I got the out of key
though maybe there's something here
I won't open of course [ __ ] all right oh
oh I know I know let's go through your
all she pen
they won't of course open up and ready
step me up
oh yeah here always you pendants over
here no wait I'm here oh she pen like a
she yes
you static all right here we go you guys
you're all game I guess
hey hey Rosie what the hell's going out
if I don't like her no it'd be you I
don't know I don't know dude just banish
it the hip but what the [ __ ] really hit
the finest town what the Vice is a good
thing
I blew della ask her you guys you're
dead dude I think it's gonna eat your
asses but I like my ass okay count it
[ __ ] down to kg they'll find a way out
of here dude right over oh my god they
can't back out you bastard
oh god oh god oh yeah all right we good
we good we good we're good I'm good
we're all good all right let's do the
couch Jake I'm so [ __ ] good with this
couch that was she said if you're really
very nice what the [ __ ] oh no he got no
he didn't get Takeshi hey what happened
hmm don't tell man you just shootin this
[ __ ] thing
oh wait here's an item finally I need to
piss oh and risky hell out penny I'm
sharing another awkward 10 oh I'm gonna
save you actually I don't wanna question
okay hey got a stopper dear don't find a
[ __ ] magic winner on top of me Oh
oh my god thank you daddy
ah okay what wait huh hater is meeting
the easy hey I can take it seems us
though I wanted to talk to the lasso I
have some questions
what are you people why do you exist er
listen to you I didn't do anything to
you but know what your ignore me then I
guess it's bye-bye alright this iron
coffin
oh there's no [ __ ] closet here ah oh
[ __ ] the whole [ __ ]
did you see that [ __ ] oh holy cows
everywhere oh god now I'm in trouble
though huh yeah I imagine it your
friends are going to hear boom boom [ __ ]
are you Sheamus King I'm askin oh oh
he's fast he's fast he's fast
awesome shut up Jim is Gianni scum
Reinhardt
I freaking loathe a character hey boy
King insane if there's one thing I've
learned from all of this is that when
you go to an empty mansion on the
outskirts of town that everyone says and
mastering it nothing good can ever come
out of it alright those South Park Ione
Adam I don't know whoever if I can say
that without hilarious hope you enjoyed
I can feared no I can't stop enough see
you tomorrow haha
what